hello internet welcome to whoa start a
bit early there don't worry though
auto-feed boss just call me the batter
the term entity
hello Internet welcome to film theory
have you guys ever seen terminator is
this audience old enough to appreciate a
good burly Austrian accent who else out
there would look back on Terminator 2
slowly sinking into lava thumbs up and
give it to slowly sinking into lava
thumbs ups the unwanted - though you're
on your own
regardless of some of the turns the
franchise has had over the years one
thing you have to admit is how awesome a
job the movies do at creating a dark
post apocalypse where robots have taken
over and humans fight for their very
survival it's the kind of scenario that
gets the old Furious cogsa turning is
this kind of world just the stuff of
nightmares or is the world of the
Terminator our great big beautiful
machine infested post-apocalyptic
tomorrow could a world in which all of
humanity is enslaved to an all-powerful
supercomputer like terminators Skynet
ever possibly become a reality should we
be worried about evil killer robots who
look and act like people believe me
Watson already creeps me out a bit did
you see him decimate the competition on
Jeopardy so come with me if you want to
live once again proving that impressions
not my strong suit in the original
Terminator our protagonist Kyle Reese
described a future where the infamous
Skynet came online and destroyed the
world in 1997 well it was the future for
1984 it's the past now time you fickle
fickle mistress
ah 1997 a day when a younger pimp Lear
matpat was attending his first middle
school dance and grooving out to Shania
Twain's man I feel like a woman those
were the glory days anyways the only
Armageddon that 1997 resulted in was my
to die for sixth-grade fashion sense so
we move on Terminator 3 portrayed a
similar Armageddon taking place in 2004
yeah I know what you're thinking
Facebook did launch that year so we were
definitely seeing signs at the end times
but it was an Armageddon or at least not
as for
in the movie today we're all still
around killer cyborg men with dare I say
excellent dental work aren't patrolling
the streets and all the color in the
world hasn't become that weird grayish
blue however the newest film Terminator
Genisys predicts that the take over from
our robotic overlords will occur in as
little as two years 2017
now the other films got their dates
wrong so this one couldn't possibly be
right either right I mean it couldn't be
right we're all not gonna die in two
years are we let's just take a look and
find out the truth behind the story
first what exactly would need to happen
for a rogue AI like Skynet to take over
the world well at its core terminator
ones apocalypse happens because Skynet a
program designed specifically for
military use revolts against its
creators and launches all of the USS
nukes killing billions in the blink of
an eye it's then able to take control of
all military machinery jacked into its
systems and use it against the surviving
human resistance now you might think
we're quite a few years away from making
that kind of blanket military strike but
it turns out that weaponized machines
for reality and this sort of
robopocalypse is actually a lot closer
than it was when the first view
Terminator films were being made if you
don't believe me that this is a big deal
we'll take a listen to what some of the
world's smartest scientific minds are
saying about advances and weaponized tag
quotes we could one day lose control of
AI systems via the rise of super
intelligences that do not act in
accordance with human wishes and that
such powerful systems would threaten
humanity
end quote this line doesn't come from a
sci-fi movie it's a real letter
presented at two international joint
conferences on artificial intelligence
in January of this year
signed by Stephen Hawking Elon Musk of
SpaceX and
slaw Fame Steve Wozniak Apple guy who
isn't Steve Jobs and many many many more
these science and tech geniuses are
genuinely worried about killer machines
taking over in the future and you know
what maybe we should be too
right now our killer robots are just
called drones the kind that can
parachute in your latest dating advice
book from amazon.com and they're quickly
becoming just another one of those
technology things we take for granted in
our everyday lives but drones have been
around for a lot longer than they've
been delivering bulk bags of cheez-its
to your doorstep in fact they were
originally developed in the 70s and the
first weaponized drone was used in war
by Iran in the late 1980s during the
iran-iraq war and the United States
invested heavily in unmanned aerial
vehicles or UAVs for all you Cod heads
during the first Gulf War in the 90s the
program was incredibly successful which
led to the u.s. to up its production of
drones for use in war
most recently armed drone strikes have
been used heavily in the war on
terrorism across the Middle East as of
June 2015 the total death toll from US
drone strikes was estimated to exceed
6,000 with up to 890 civilians and about
a hundred and seventy-five children
killed in Pakistan alone that's a lot of
innocents killed and these sorts of
drones aren't just being rolled out in
the Middle East drones are becoming more
and more common in North America as well
several law enforcement agencies across
the US have been using drones for
surveillance and many bureaus have been
requesting permission to equip their
UAVs with tear gas and guns that fire
rubber bullets non-lethal weaponry to be
sure but still weaponry in the hands of
computer-controlled devices and that
starts to get scary know you might be
thinking yeah that's a little creepy I
guess but there still are drones we have
control of from well you might want to
think again because things can get
hacked we previously talked about how
easily hackers can get into everything
we own from our phones to our computers
to our cars in our watch underscore dogs
episodes over on game theory and drones
are no exception
in 2011 a CIA stealth drone was hijacked
by a group of Iranians who not only
brought it down but did it in a way that
they could reverse-engineer the
technology for themselves and the
craziest part of this the instructions
on how they did this can be found with a
quick google search now we hear
theorists Inc don't condone this sort of
behavior so we're gonna elect not to
share how to find this information but
for those of you smart enough to use
related keywords and know how to click a
button with a giant magnifying glass on
it you'll find yourself a PDF explaining
exactly how to generate fake signals
that can fool the drones GPS receivers
as well as how to replace legitimate
signals with fake ones can you imagine
if a rogue AI program like Skynet were
able to get into systems of drones like
this it's a wild hypothetical scenario
right hypothetical might not be the
right word to describe it
in early July a massive vulnerability
was found in Adobe Flash you know the
program that allows you to play slime
volleyball an addicting games.com which
allowed hackers to install malware on
thousands of systems without users even
realizing anything was wrong later that
same month Microsoft rushed out an
emergency patch to fix a ginormous
security bug that allowed hackers to
remotely execute malicious code on
computers running any supported version
of Windows - gaping security holes that
affect pretty much anyone who has ever
touched a computer ever but you know
what the scariest part about this is
several parts of the US government
including branches as large and powerful
as the Navy currently use Windows as
their operating system which when you
think about it makes sense that they'd
be Windows people anyone I think Navy my
mind doesn't jump to silhouettes dancing
in front of neon colored backgrounds but
serious talk if a rogue AI found a
similar hole and simultaneously
exploited it on every system it could
that's starting to sound a lot like
Skynet isn't it
so we've managed to lay the foundation
or at the very least the major building
blocks for a Skynet Eska Doom program to
take over our computer systems are
imperfect and vulner
and our military and police forces are
operated by machines more and more every
day so what's missing why aren't we the
loyal subjects of an all-powerful Robo
overlord already well the answer to that
question is true artificial intelligence
in all of the films Skynet is a
self-aware system that's what made it so
dangerous it was able to comprehend
things like life and death the fact that
it existed and even had a
self-preservation instinct that's why it
launched all of those nukes and killed
humans in the first place it saw us
humans as a threat to its existence and
it got scared and if all of that sounds
to you like the plot of Avengers age of
Ultron you're dead on no obviously no
technology like this currently exists in
our world but believe it or not it's not
entirely out of the realm of possibility
in fact it's a subject that's been
seriously speculated on by scientists
and science fiction writers alike really
there's only one thing standing between
us and true sentient AI like Skynet and
that thing is time eventually it will
happen in an event known as the
singularity now I'm sure a lot of you
have heard that word tossed around in
the past but let's define it here the
technological singularity will be a
point in time where technology becomes
so powerful and the exponential
advancement of science will be so quick
that a super intelligence is created
singularity itself is a term borrowed
from astrophysics it refers to a point
in space-time or normal physics no
longer apply think the center of a black
hole where there's so much mass that
time ceases to be a factor now the
singularity could be achieved in one of
four ways but to save us all time let's
just talk about the one that Skynet fits
into we're a computer network becomes so
advanced that it becomes self-aware if
that were to ever happen it would
basically be impossible for us humans to
keep off a computer that was aware of
itself could use all of its intelligence
to design an even better computer which
would then design a better computer
which would then design a better
computer and so on and so forth it would
get to the point where a supercomputer
could design an even better
supercomputer in milliseconds and if it
decided to turn against us like Skynet
did well we probably wouldn't stand a
chance
so why are we talking about this now
again this sounds like something out of
science fiction there is no way a
computer he gets so advanced so quickly
and it especially isn't feasible in the
next few years
right right well my dear loyal long
departed theorists you know I wouldn't
bring it up for no reason
technology is fickle due to the nature
of electronics Computer Sciences
advanced at a much faster rate than
other fields this is so well documented
that there's even a neat little name for
the concept it's called Moore's law and
it states that the number of transistors
basically computer thinkI bits on a
circuit board doubles every two years
now this seems like a very simple and
very rough estimation but let me tell
you this has held true for decades and
has only slowed down recently in 2015
representatives at Intel stated that
quote our cadence today is slower to two
and a half years than to still that is
incredibly quick for the type of
advancements we're making in layman's
terms this means that computers are
getting really powerful really quickly
and if you want proof of those
advancements just look at the landscape
of computers in the past decades forty
years ago in the 70s a computer could
take up an entire room in a laboratory
30 years ago computers were almost
non-existent in the general market and
their screens could only display texture
rudimentary drawings and pixel art 20
years ago in the 90s while a bit more
common computer systems weren't very
powerful they were mostly used for
office worker to play really on advanced
video games 10 years ago in the offs
computers were now common but garbage
compared to today's standards
I remember once having to buy a thumb
drive for school and 156 megabit drive
costs right around $50 $50 today a drive
with that little memory space literally
wouldn't be worth the plastic and metal
used to create it the phones that many
of us have in our pockets today have
more power than what was used to go to
the moon in the 6th
and our very best computers can render
three-dimensional imagery so realistic
that you might be unable to distinguish
it from the real thing and for as simple
as it may seem models created using
Moore's Law outlined all of this and
some scientists have been using it to
predict future trends in technology one
such man is named Ray Kurzweil computer
scientist inventor futurist and director
of engineering at Google or is an
alphabet now corporate maneuvering
confuses me Kurzweil is the definition
of a genius and a pioneer of computing
technology having been heavily involved
with optical character recognition text
to speech and speech recognition
technology in the past he was also named
one of PBS's 16 revolutionaries who made
America read his bio it's very clear he
knows what he's talking about he's also
been one of the loudest voices within
the so called singularity community and
has gone so far as to chart out a graph
of real-world technological growth and
compare it to what Moore's laws
predicted remember who I said Moore's
law outlined the advancements made in
the past few decades and how it lined up
shockingly well with tech that's now
being released
well Kurzweil noticed this back in the
80s and charted out how technology would
continue to improve for decades to come
using these numbers Kurzweil predicted
and maintains that the singularity will
occur around 2045 30 years from now so
going back to our original question here
is terminators future possible where
Skynet takes over in 2017 oh that dates
off the mark just like its predecessors
were before it any don't get me wrong
we have weaponized AI and massive
vulnerabilities in our technology but
we're nowhere close to having artificial
intelligence yet Skynet's not coming in
two years it's coming in 30 but hey
that's just a theory
hey if you like the videos this channel
produces and want to help us out then
please consider getting a free audiobook
from our sponsor for this video
audible.com just type in audible.com
slash film T fil fil with T fil MT or
click the link in the description it's
film T since film theorist is just
really long audible is not only the
leading provider of audiobooks with over
180,000 titles to download they've also
been a big believer in YouTube creators
which is a big reason why this channel
is able to exist in the first place
hats like this mean that I'm able to
expand the team and make you more videos
faster and on YouTube we're cheap easy
content gets algorithmic favored in a
lot of ways channels like film theorist
and game theorists are fighting a losing
battle supporters like audible allow us
to fight that battle giving you high
quality thoughtful content on a regular
basis and seriously audible is awesome I
listen to audio books all the time
during the LA commute and at three hours
into and out of the city most days I
burn through these things in fact for
this episode I listen to Terminator 3
rise of the machines in audiobook form
it's actually better than the movies and
yeah it's available on audible right now
I've moved on to the Martian I saw the
movie and of course we're doing an
episode on it to be honest once again I
liked the book better than the movie I
wasn't sold on the movie the book though
much much better it's fascinating for
anyone who loves space and science and
assuming you watch this channel those
are things that you're interested in and
again it's also available in audible
long story short it's a win-win-win you
get a free book you help audible and
audible helps us get you more videos
it's a virtuous cycle so remember that's
audible.com slash film t-fal keep doing
it fil MT now go listen to some books on
how to survive the robot apocalypse
doing this video made me really paranoid